[Music]
welcome to a special edition of a
spectator podcast except this isn't
really a podcast every week during
lockdown we are asking three of our
writers to read out what they've written
for the magazine the idea is that
normally the magazine is passed between
readers and their friends so each
article can be read two three four or
even five times but this won't be
happening so much in her that we're not
allowed to see each other so first we
have Rachel Johnson reading her diary
then we have Paul woods about the
morality of covert testing Emma knew
backstreet testings which have crept up
and then finally we have Simon Barnes
about the beauty and the art and the
points of boxing first Rachel Johnson
when the post office and stores closed
in our village on Exmoor my youngest
stared out of the car window as we drove
past and saw it's dreaded closed silent
for sale placard outside for the first
time that's my whole childhood he wailed
gone as an over-50 who's had peak
everything I can't complain out loud
anyway but I find the losses for younger
generations too painful to contemplate
no travel no parties no pubs no clubs no
sport no sex no education a life unlived
online for the forseeable given how
badly Oliver took that one tiny but
vital enterprise shutting up shop I've
been surprised and impressed by how well
millions have adapted to the closure of
the country lockdown has worked because
against all expectation there turned out
to be many more acceptors and sufferers
than resistors the three condemned ik
personalities identified by King's
College I'm keeping a note of some of
the less seismic adaptations everything
is a family now Priti Patel speaks of
the bluelight family of emergency
workers Rishi sunic of the Health and
Social Care family journalists of the
superior ability of female leaders from
Iceland to Taiwan
to care for the human family even my
shredded wheat packet meet the shredded
wheat family honey and nut spelt and
barley which somehow makes me think of a
litter of cute blond puppies the ads
that pop up on my screen and no longer
forty dresses and for some reason
multivitamins but plastic visors rubber
gloves and fashion Paisley face mark the
ads that pop up on my screen and no
longer forty dresses and for some reason
multivitamins but plastic visors rubber
gloves and fashion Paisley face masks PR
emails no longer hope I've been enjoying
the lovely sunshine but the time safe in
these unprecedented and strange times
well that's one way of glossing how many
of us have interpreted the wartime
instructions to stay at home and save
lives by binging on banana bread and box
sets for six weeks while forwarding
funny tic TOCs on whatsapp Amazon
Facebook Zoom Google their corporate
winners and Captain Tom's one of the
many heroes but my friend Mary killin of
this parish is a nation sweetheart
starring as she does with her husband
Giles wood from there Wiltshire cottage
aka the grata CH on gogglebox
as we sit on our sofas scoffing our
homemade banana bread it turns out that
what we love is a telly program that
reflects our own selves back to us ie a
nation of people on sofas watching a
television show about more people on
sofas watching television this
contagious solipsism has made our own
dear surely soon Dame Mary the Vera Lynn
of Co vyd Y is fishing band Y a golf
course is closed and public tennis
courts pad locked given that these are
healthful and wholesome activities that
can be enjoyed while accommodating
health and safety guidelines I asked my
husband who used to work for the
National Trust which has closed its
entire estate it
the car parks he said they're worried
people weren't socially distance on the
tarmac while icy lockdown as a go to
jail card my husband regards it as a
golden ticket I never want it to end I
over here chuckling on the landline to
mail chums as I returned from the shops
laden with his wine whiskey fruit nut
and cigarettes it's so peaceful not
seeing anyone we used to joke brexit
saved our marriage as we were so united
in the remain cause readers must join me
in zum prayers that what europe hath
joined together let not covet nineteen
put asunder
especially when I hear him chuckle as he
lights up a more bruh it's what I've
always wanted I may never go back to
London again what I can't do from Exmoor
where we've been since March before
Locke was doubt is present my new show
on LBC our Wi-Fi is weaker than M&S gin
Norton and I wouldn't know how I have
key worker status and can travel for
work that I can't do from home last week
I left the west country for the first
time in six weeks and headed into a
deserted Leicester Square in a taxi that
had a plastic visor to shield me and the
driver from any diseased droplets I was
soon with my own muff technical term
alone in the studio everyone else
sitting in the gallery halfway through
they played a clip of the Kiwi ICU nurse
who looked after the PM and there was
nothing for it I had to say something
about my brother's life-saving treatment
at st. Thomas's I wish I'd said it
better and said it differently and said
more but the key message was thank you I
thought I'd have to take out a large
onion to show emotion but the tears
almost came to my eyes anyway oh yes and
I can't count how many listeners started
calls to me with the kind words
welcome to the LBC family this week no
doubt I'll be accepting continuing
congratulations for becoming an auntie
again which is all splendid that was
ritual Johnson
now here's poet my friend
let's just call him by his initial D is
an instantly recognizable type in the
Middle East the middleman he's always
chasing the next deal always about to
make millions one scheme was to build a
London Eye in a flyblown town in the
Levant another was to buy a Trump sex
tape for ten million dollars invited me
to watch the negotiations they ended
with a sociopathic Russian gangster
ringing up in the night threatening to
kill my children we know where you live
his latest scheme is to get the British
government to buy coronavirus test kits
from Turkey this could be the big score
for biotech companies testing is a new
gold rush and there's a touch of Dell
boy about my friend he's right about the
need for test kits in fact to get out of
the crisis caused by the corona virus we
might have to test on an immense
unprecedented almost unimaginable scale
as d we'll be overjoyed to learn 34
experts have written a joint letter to
the British government saying that every
single person in the country should be
tested once a week that's ten million
tests a day for 34 experts are mostly
professors of Epidemiology or public
health there's also a Nobel Prize winner
in economics they're calling not just
for mass testing but for universal
testing that's never been done in a
large country like the UK their letter
was published by The Lancet and the
authors argue that without universal
testing and selective quarantine Britain
will be stuck in a cycle of relaxing and
then reimposing the lock down with fresh
surges in the epidemic each time they
write these cycles will kill tens and
perhaps hundreds of thousands of people
before a vaccine becomes available the
letter was organized by Julian Peto a
professor of Epidemiology at the London
School of Hygiene he's 74 and a bit of a
curmudgeon he tells me the government
got the wrong advice from the wrong
people modelers and sociologists he says
the modelers were bloody useless because
they didn't put the right thing in their
model the sociologists were bloody
useless because they
thought people wouldn't put up with the
lockdown until there was a big pile of
corpses nobody thought of just testing
it's bloody obvious that they didn't
Peter says that with universal testing
only the infectious would have to be
kept at home he thinks that might be 1
to 2 percent of the population and would
quickly drop to almost nothing
he goes on this is a way to go straight
back to normal life if someone tested
positive for the virus the whole
household would have to quarantine
themselves he says strict quarantine is
very very important that's the only
thing to take this disease out of
communities I don't care if we get herd
immunity I don't want to kill 200,000
people and ruin the economy The Lancet
letter is talking about the swab test
which shows if you have the virus not
the antibody test which roughly speaking
shows if you have had it a swab is taken
from the nose or mouth and tested to see
if there's genetic material from the
virus the trouble is that the analysis
is done with a specialized piece of lab
equipment called a PCR machine the
government has scooped up some that were
in private hands and has been
centralizing the work in a few labs this
has meant firstly the test results can
take days to come back and secondly that
the government has struggled to reach
its target of a hundred thousand tests a
day for NHS staff and key workers Peter
and the other signatures of the letter
have worked out that to do 10 million
tests a day would take 14,000 machines
working constantly no problem he says
almost every single lab in the country
has a PCR machine there are certainly
more than 14,000 if only the government
would trust individual scientists to get
on with the work he says it didn't occur
to me until I thought about it that we
did actually have the firepower to test
everyone
you could even rig up a test without
specialized equipment with little more
than a water bath at 63 degrees Celsius
a sorcerer and a thermometer the
so-called arty lamp test this slightly
barmy Heath Robinson approach appeals to
the spirit of Dunkirk that Peter and his
colleagues want to invoke a flotilla of
small labs private and university coming
together to save the nation his group
says that national testing would cost
about fourteen billion pounds a year
that they say is a small fraction of the
economic costs of lockdown
these ideas are controversial peter has
been attacked in a blog post by Liam
Smith who happens to be the Dean of his
own faculty at the London School of
Hygiene no politics are as vicious as
academic politics as the old saying goes
precisely or usually because the stakes
are so small except now the stakes are
extremely high when the public inquiry
into K vid 19 is held it may be
revealing to see what role academic
rivalries played in the conflicting
advice given to ministers professor
Smith blogpost did make two important
points the first is that testing people
a week apart could see the infectious
out in about four days before the virus
is detected and quarantine put in place
the second is to question whether
Britain could get hold of the huge
amounts of chemical reagents needed for
10 million tests a day especially with
every developed country in the world
trying to buy the same thing a month ago
the Deputy Prime Minister as we may call
him Michael Gove said that a shortage of
reagents was holding up testing I asked
the chemical business association which
represents chemical suppliers in the UK
if this was true its chief executive
Peter Newport said that following Gail's
remarks he'd asked ministers what
exactly was needed he was still waiting
to hear back he thought it was quite
possible to provide the raw materials
for professor Peters 10 million tests a
day though the complex reagents would
have to be made by biotech companies
Anthony bellum who runs a biotech
company called a pakore told me this
could be done on a big enough scale for
national testing he said it's going to
cost an awful lot but it's possible he
said his company's offer of test kits
for the NHS had been ignored until the
Daily Mail wrote about it it was a
similar story for the company
represented by my friend the Turkish
middleman
they offered to supply a hundred
thousand tests a day but they never
heard back Peto is outraged he tells me
I'm sure we can bloody well make enough
and if not we can buy it it can't be
done because you haven't got enough
reverse transcriptase tell that to
Churchill in 1939 one government
Minister I spoke to told me that a
national system of testing for everyone
even those without symptoms wasn't worth
the trouble and expense because the swab
test could be unreliable this can happen
because a good enough swab isn't taken
or perhaps there's a mistake with the
reagents as much as 30% of the time it
can give a false negative disastrously
telling people they're safe to leave
home when they're not the minister said
that only those with symptoms should be
tested followed by a rigorous effort to
find everyone they've been near than
isolating everyone with the virus this
is the system of tests track and trace
planned by the health secretary Matt
Hancock first four key workers then four
others
the problem say supporters of universal
testing that it might work only when the
number of cases is very low soon the
system gets overwhelmed another lockdown
is imposed and the whole cycle starts
again a report by the Safra Center for
ethics at Harvard University supports
test track and trace calling for 20
million Americans to be tested every day
but the report also concedes that this
might not keep up with the virus and it
says that testing a hundred million
Americans a day could be the only way to
avoid another lockdown this is universal
testing but what about the antibody test
this is the test to show whether you've
had the virus and have built immunity to
it surely this is the way to avoid the
whole country living under the yoke of
constant testing antibody tests are
certainly quick and easy you prick your
finger and put a couple of drops of
blood on something that looks very much
like a pregnancy test some of these are
circulating in Notting Hill a new W 11
status symbol it's a question of knowing
the right venture capitalists
apparently but for now antibody tests
are more unreliable than the swab test
and even if you've had the virus no one
knows yet how long you keep your
immunity even worse if the antibody test
is done too early you could appear
immune but still be shedding the virus
the antibody test alone may not tell you
whose infectious so far the debate has
been about whether to ease the lockdown
slowly and get to a final total of
people who have had corona virus in a
way that doesn't overwhelm our hospitals
or whether to ease it quickly hoping
that the Swedish model is right and you
arrive at the same destination with less
catastrophic damage to the economy
there's a kind of fatalism to both
positions a belief that eventually a
certain number of people will get the
virus as many crematorium fires will be
lit either way the advocates of
universal testing and selective
quarantine don't accept that lie close
cartoon of a British soldier standing on
a rock and shaking his fist at the enemy
very well alone they would like to
remain defiant in the face of
dispiriting odds perhaps this is an
image that may appeal to our prime
minister as he gets back to work after
his convalescence that was Paul woods
and finally Simon barns why do we box
it's an almost ludicrously inefficient
form of combat the last thing the SAS
suggested soldiers to do is put their
dukes up
but boxing is nonetheless the world's
leading combat sport millions watch
boxing in lockdown and when were allowed
out thousands will head first to the pub
then out into the streets and car parks
to throw punches at each other's heads
why I have the answer it came to me by a
combination of joanna lumley
and a fight i once witnessed between
cobras boxing is not a great form of
combat not if your aim is to put your
opponent out of action fast but Joanna
sitting a boxing gym in Cuba for a
recent television program made a crucial
point it's the most natural thing in the
world you put your fists up she was
right there are Sumerian images of
boxing 5,000 years old evidence for
boxing has been found in ancient Babylon
and on Egyptian papyrus boxing was part
of the Olympic Games in 688 BC what's
more when Voltas fought hasit in the
battle of 2x at emanuel school they put
their fists up when my neighbor are
tuned on lama island hong kong took
exception to a visiting Japanese
engineer he conveyed his reproof with
swinging fists it's what people do it
seems not to vary from culture to
culture it's a human thing if you want
to win a fight
the default ploy is to kick your
opponent in the balls and then perhaps
in the head saves untold trouble the
boxers don't do that because it's
against the rules and barroom fighters
tend not to either because there seems
to be a powerful inhibition that stops
them so people swing punches and heads
and problem is that unless you're
wearing boxing gloves it hurts
hitting bone against bone isn't smart
Ben Stokes the England cricketer broke
his wrist punching a locker after he was
out first ball and had to miss the World
t20 Championship later he was in trouble
for a street fight over zealously
protecting a gay couple demonstrating
that it hurts less when your fists are
anesthetized by alcohol the pain in the
aggressors hands acts as a safety
measure padded gloves were introduced
into boxing by the Marquess of
Queensbury in 1867 they don't protect
boxers from the savagery of bare-knuckle
fighting they protect their hands so
they can land serious concussive blows
in comparative comfort boxing is a
highly specialized form of combat
a limited target and fists that don't
hurt so let's get to those cobras the
most efficient way for a cobra to win a
fight is obvious after all they are
armed with large fangs that inject
lethal venom but the two male snakes I
saw fighting in Sri Lanka weren't trying
to bite each other
instead they were wrapped round each
other like a stick of barley sugar and
we're trying to bare each other to the
ground lethal creatures choosing a
non-lethal form of combat it's a pattern
you can find repeated again and again in
parlor rounds don't try to Gore each
other's entrails out they lock horns
humpback whales posture at each other
birds sing many primate species fight
and make up again as explained in France
de vars classic work of ethology
peacemaking among primates in which he
contends that the reconciliations are
more important than the combat lethal
combat is far from unknown in many
species but generally speaking it's the
last resort and happens when two equal
males can't resolve a dispute any other
way as a generalization combat is a
genuine test of skill strength and
experience but lives and not often at
risk ritual predominates over lethal
danger and that is why humans box boxing
is not efficient but it's not supposed
to be efficient the whole idea is that
it's inefficient it hurts the hands too
much to carry on for long but it's quite
good at sorting out the winner from the
loser as a bonus the loser carries the
marks of combat for a good week or so
afterwards black eyes a swollen nose cut
lips red ears an advertisement of his
opponents enhanced or retained status
hence the ancient jest you should see
the other guy
more dangerous forms of combat are
mostly rejected people sometimes get
dangerously carried away with a fallen
opponent but in the main a punch-up is
an effective way of settling a dispute
with minimal damage it hurts
and humiliates sure but both parties
walk away in Nevel shoots novel the
checkerboard corporal dougie Brent is a
commando who takes his combat training
into a pub he has lost his appreciation
of pub fight etiquette and intentionally
kills his man and is tried for murder
murder is not supposed to happen in a
pub fight I had always assumed that the
fist fighting convention came from
watching boxing or from watching films
in which characters throw massive
punches without sustaining so much as a
sore knuckle but where did boxers or
filmmakers get their ideas from the fact
is that fist fighting is an archetypal
form of combat it's the way people fight
when they're not fighting for their
lives in normal circumstances when
people fight for honor or precedents or
access to females they put their fists
up and afterwards though the winner is a
good deal happier than the loser they
carry on living and breathing as Cobras
do that was Simon Barnes and that's all
from our podcasts I'm not even quite
sure what to call it our audio reads and
if you can think of a good name and do
let us know on podcasts at spectators Co
dot uk' we're always very keen to hear
from you guys especially and during
lockdown if you've got any thoughts
about the format of this particular
podcast or any of our other podcasts
then do let us know normally we'd get
together in the editors office and
brainstorm but we can't do so much of
that nowadays so with your help I'm sure
we can
get a little bit better thanks very much
for listening and thanks to Cindy you
are Buddhism
[Music]